x-men was directed by Bryan Singer and
starred a cast that went on to prove
extremely successful in a gigantic
franchise that a lot of people have
loved for many years and since Logan is
coming out in March and it is the final
Hugh Jackman portrayal of Wolverine so
he says I decided to be the perfect time
to fill in the gaps to the x-men movies
I haven't reviewed and those movies are
x-men 1 2 3 and origins hopefully but
we're not quite there yet we're still
talking about some respectable x-men
films here this one came out as I said
in the year 2000 and was very
influential in regards to the early
2000s superhero scene because at this
time we had really only had Batman and
Superman in big movies before at least
that had worked except for the first
blade which I really like this was that
film where people went wow this could be
a thing like superhero movies could
really prosper and not just make money
but be good one of the reasons that this
first x-men movie works so well is Bryan
Singer and the writers they understood
what makes the characters in the comics
work it's not just about mutant powers
and action scenes and really amazing
special effects x-men is about prejudice
it's about fear it's about
discrimination and this film portrays
that extremely well as we have a world
in which people are very frightened by
mutants we have politicians who are
trying to make it legal
that mutants have to register themselves
make themselves public make it known
what they can do because mankind's
afraid of them so this movie not only
has amazing action sequences and a lot
of fun cool comic-book stuff it's a very
mature tale about discrimination and
fear and that's one of the things that
works so well about this first x-men
movie and I'm so glad they maintain that
in this film because if you've seen like
the 90s Fantastic Four or even the 2000s
Fantastic Four or fucking fan 4 stick or
Superman 3 or Superman 4 or Batman
Forever or Batman and Robin you know
that superhero movies can make the
mistake of just thinking that all they
have to do is be a superhero
movie all people want to see are cool
costumes and special effects when they
go to these films right comic books are
just dumb the only people who like comic
books are idiots right wrong no I mean
comics have a lot of depths and if you
ever take the time to read any of the
x-men comics which I have you're going
to see a lot of that present in those
books and that's one of the reasons why
I'm so glad they maintained that more
mature level of depth throughout this
film and the next one in particular
another thing they got so right was the
casting we can look back now after
seeing so many films with these
characters and really praised this first
movie for casting Patrick Stewart as
Professor X that's perfect casting Ian
McKellen as Magneto fantastic but let's
talk about one specific person in
particular and it happens to be my
favorite actor portraying a comic-book
character ever and that is of course
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine Jackman is
still portraying the exact same
character seventeen years later and
nobody is asking for him to quit that's
how good he was in this first movie and
the ones that followed his introduction
in this movie where rogue finds him in
this dive and everyone's challenging him
to a fight and he's able to win money
and actually support himself just by
kicking ass it's so perfect that's such
a great introduction to that character
and he really proved his naysayers wrong
because going into this film Hugh
Jackman had a lot of hate similar to
Daniel Craig when he got the role of
bond a lot of people are like no we know
it worked now but I remember back in the
early 2000s when I first saw this movie
I actually rented the VHS tape from the
library I didn't see it in theaters and
I sat down with this movie and I was
just blown away I was blown away because
at that time I was really into the x-men
cartoon and seeing all these characters
portrayed so well was just such a breath
of fresh air from the normal superhero
stuff I was used to at that time I keep
having to reiterate at that time I was
like Batman forever Batman and Robin
that's where we're at here you know
steel with Shaquille O'Neal this movie
changed the game but what I think this
movie doesn't get enough credit for is
the direction Bryan Singer has a lot of
really great sequences in this movie
almost every scene has a lot of energy
within every shot he always tries to
keep the camera moving or make it
interesting he makes his edits not too
fast but not too quick either the
sequence of which Wolverine is
discovering the school for the first
time and he's running around the
corridors hearing Professor X in his
mind is really thrilling
it was also wise to make the audience
follow rogue at first portrayed by Anna
Paquin because her character is the most
naive in this entire film we see her
discover her mutation when she reaches
puberty and the pure horror in her face
when she discovers that she can't touch
anyone without essentially killing them
but the audience is introduced to this
world through her because she discovers
things she wants to ask questions and so
we as the audience want to ask questions
- especially if you're not initiated
with the x-men comics so it was smart to
start with her character so like I said
they got the casting right they got the
themes of x-men right did they get the
action right yeah this movie's badass
mystique versus Wolverine the entire
finale is very thrilling and it's not
just because the action sequences are
cool it's because we understand what's
at stake we understand how magneto feels
about humankind we understand how
Professor X feels and how humankind
feels so since we understand where
everyone's brain is at it makes the
action a lot more fun it's not just
Wolverine slicing and dicing
it's thematically interesting and that's
one of the best things about x-men I'm
gonna give x-men and a I actually think
this first film is very underrated I
don't think it gets the respect it
deserves especially now when you look at
like you know Civil War and everything
and people go back and watch x-men movie
for the first time you're like yeah
whatever in the year 2000 I must
reiterate this movie changed the game so
guys thanks so much for watching my
review of x-men I'm coming up very soon
with x-men - x-men United which is
apparently what it's called despite the
fact that that's never actually shown in
the movie it's kind of just X - but yeah
whatever
Logan's coming out soon I can't wait to
talk about x-men with you guys thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you